You don't have anything. Excuse me. I didn't
have a bag with me.
This is the drink you mentioned. I
warmed it up with my human skin.
[Music] A
warm drink.  Is there any
hope for you? If that's the case, then
what do you mean? My body has been stiff lately, and
all of them are in particularly serious condition. What's more
serious is my head.
Do you want me to rub your ass? No, it's
fine if you just trample on that beautiful ass of yours. You're a
devil, as you might expect from an unusual hobby. Just stop doing what you want, and I'll stop and trample on it.
Don't crush me.  Should I
avoid it or should I really step on it?
Aren't I about to make a big mistake that I can't go back from?However, if this is just a
little bit of hope, will it really be over after just
a little bit?Then the tip of my
shoe will end.  It's just a little bit,
so I'll put up with everything else. It's so
weird to be in a public place. My
right foot,
yeah, my body can move freely.
Wait.
EN